conway there and we're taking you live
to brussels now because nato secretary
general jens stoltenberg is speaking
let's listen we will also decide on a
new nato strategic concept setting out
our position on russia
on emerging challenges and for the first
time on china
and in this context i welcome that the
leaders of our asia-pacific partners
will take part in our summit for the
first time
last but not least
better burden sharing and resourcing of
our alliance
and the historic
applications for membership by finland
and sweden
at this ministerial in brussels
yesterday and today we have made
progress on many of these areas
last night we met with ukrainian defense
minister resnikov
we addressed the imperative need for our
continued support
as russia conducts a relentless war of
attrition against ukraine
nato allies and partners have been
providing ukraine
unprecedented support
so that it can defend itself against
moscow's aggression
allies have announced additional
assistance
including much needed heavy weapons and
long range systems
also discussed plans to support the
country for the longer term
we are putting together a nato
comprehensive assistance package for
ukraine
helping ukraine improve interoperability
with nato
transition from soviet era
to modern nato equipment
and further strengthening security
institutions
yesterday over 40 nations nato allies
and partners took part in the meeting of
the ukraine support contact group led by
the united states
and committed to continue to uphold
ukraine's right to self-defense
georgia finland sweden and the european
union
also joined the meeting of nato defense
ministers
we made clear
that all countries have the right to
choose
their own path with outside
with outside without outside
interference
russia's aggression is a game changer
so nato must maintain credible
deterrence and strong defense
today ministers addressed the scale and
the design
of our future posture
and how we can step up across all
domains
with substantial strengthening our
presence capabilities and readiness
this will mean more nato forward
deployed combat formations
to strengthen our battle battle groups
in the eastern part of the alliance more
air sea and cyber defenses
as well as pre-positioned equipment and
weapon stockpiles
and a new force model with more forces
at higher redness
and specific forces pre-assigned to the
defense of a specific allies to enable
much faster reinforcement
a number of allies have committed to
contribute to our stronger presence in
the eastern part of our alliance
but we still have some work to do as we
look to the summit
where i expect further announcements
the substantial strengthening of
deterrence and defense is necessary for
our security
but it does not come for free so
ministers also discuss the importance of
resourcing our decisions
we have seen seven consecutive years of
rising defense investment across europe
and canada
allies are also contributing to nato
deployments and exercises
and investing in more high-end
capabilities including fifth generation
aircraft and emerging technologies
now is the time to keep up the momentum
so we can continue to preserve peace
prevent conflict and protect our people
and with that i'm ready to take your
questions
okay frank italia my name is
in the last row
there
thanks a lot uh secretary tomaszka
vancouver
secretary general um
the pope
has made a few remarks on nato's
possible contribution to the war in
ukraine he
said that we don't know the whole drama
unfolding behind this war which was and
i quote him somehow either provoked or
not prevented
we all know the pope can claim infer
inability for his remarks maybe not for
this one but
i'd be keen to hear your reply
thanks
so nato is a defensive alliance and the
the war in ukraine is
president putin's war this is a war
that he has decided to conduct against
the independent sovereign nation
and
what nato has been doing for many years
is to support the sovereign independent
nation in europe ukraine
train assistant wise
and equip the ukrainian armed forces
that is what nato allies and nato have
done for many years
this is not a threat to anyone this is
not a provocation and
[Music]
and and that is what we continue to do
so it is president putin
and moscow that is responsible for this
uh brutal aggression against the
independent uh
country ukraine okay we'll go to the
national news agency of ukraine
expectations in ukraine because of a big
pre-visiting ukraine i mean leaders of
france
germany and italy
i just curious if they consulted nato
before coming to kiev from the security
and military point of view
and
how that visit could be
uh influencing uh the future cooperation
in military field between the nato and
uh ukraine and the short follow-up if i
may if
ukraine now is fighting for nato values
using the nato
weaponry
is it a right time to
rise a question or consider the future
membership of ukraine in nato thank you
i welcome that leaders of nato allied
countries uh go to kiev and visit
ukraine and meet with the political
leadership meet with president zelinski
and also
see the atrocities the result of the
brutal
uh aggression by moscow and president
putin in ukraine i think that is
important to demonstrate solidarity to
convey a clear political message and
also of course
uh to have that
opportunity to consult with the
political leadership in kiev
we are
also of course
consulting with the political leadership
in kiev here in brussels in different
nato capitals
we had the defence minister reznikov
participating in the meeting yesterday
and of course we also consult
among ourselves between nato allies
as we also did yesterday uh in the
dinner where we had the european union
finland and sweden together with
minister yesterkov and all 30 nato
allies discussing their way forward in
our support to ukraine and also we had a
meeting of the u.s led support group
here at nato
yesterday more than 40 nato allies and
partners
participated in
in that meeting consulting discussing
how to
sustain
an unprecedented level of support to
ukraine and also in that context
welcomed the announcement by the united
states yesterday to further increase
support 1 billion
u.s extra for military aid including
artillery and also
long-range fires